We'll talk a bit about the pesticide.
If the term is familiar to you
It is likely that the first thing that will occur in your mind is the fat molecules,
This is true to some extent.
Fat molecules type
Commonly from the pulp,
Here's an example
On the fat molecules,
Or triglycerides.
This triglyceride is a type of polyunsaturated fat,
We will explain more about this type
In the video on the molecular structure of fat
Or triglycerides
And in the video about fat
Saturated and unsaturated.
These particles are connected
Tell us what the glycerol molecule was
It is the basis of this structure,
Linked to three molecules were fatty acids.
We will also explain this issue,
The liver has other types of fat.
But, why are all these things considered
Which will I show you also for the hand?
What is the common denominator between them and fats?
Lapid is the general term
For a type of particle
Not easily soluble in water,
Which are synthesized and aggregated
When placed in water
And do not melt
In water easily.
I pick my words well,
I did not say it was water-crazed.
There are types of lupine to be hateful and water repellent,
There are types
One side is water-resistant
And the other
Water lover.
Each of these species has a different term.
It is not what it is
Water-craving in a holistic manner
He avoids
Water repellent,
It is a non-polar molecule,
Its molecules are massed
with each other
In the water.
And other types
she has
parts
Watery
And water-loving parts
Amphibathic molecules,
We will talk about this more
In biology
When we explain phospholipid,
Which is the basis
Composition of the cell membrane.
What are all these different molecules?
Let us think together what parts are water-threatening
And what parts are water-loving.
When looking at fat you will see a hydrocarbon chain,
But do not be clear
Whether there are electrical shipments or not.
In fact, there is none.
Oxygen is negative electrical charge,
There may be a small partial negative charge
Or a partial positive charge,
Negative partial charge at oxygen
Or perhaps a partial positive charge at the carbon side,
Carbon is considered to be negatively charged
More than hydrogen, for example,
We will not be able to create a polar link,
Or hydrogen bonds,
If there are hydroxyl groups,
If what we are talking about is alcoholic.
Hydrocarbon chains
Watery
That's what fat makes
They are lumped and not dissolve in water.
These particles are here
Classified as Esther,
Because of the existence of the Ester group
Which consists of carbon bonds with oxygen,
One is a double
And the other one link.
Where one-link oxygen is also connected to a long chain of hydrocarbons,
And carbon
Connected to another long chain of hydrocarbons.
This installation
Considered
One of the basic elements
For beeswax,
Which is inherently water-loving.
And beeswax
Like any kind
Types of wax,
Considered
Of sinter,
It is hateful
Waterproof
It is sometimes used
To keep the water
Of infusion
Between spaces.
Let's talk about this example here
It is a steroid.
It is common to steroid
It is illegal
And not allowed
Which players can
BodyBuilding
To be injected
Their bodies
To enlarge muscles.
Steroid is a compound
Which consists
Of four episodes
As such,
Three of which are hexagonal carbon
And one carbon tetrahedron.
This steroid-related steroid,
Is an alcoholic steroid
Which is called sterol,
This composition
particulary
Is known
Cholesterol.
Usually people think
Cholesterol
bad thing
They always seek
To ease it,
But really
Is an important element
Of living things.
It is an effective element
In the conduct of the work of the cell,
It is important for steroid hormones
Which help
In the configuration
Human.
This is another example
Of steroid hormone
It is a hormone
Testosterone
Derived from
Cholesterol,
As you can see
Carbon rings
Composed of
Six carbonates
The ring is composed
Of five carbonates.
Double Carbon Connector
Located elsewhere,
And hydroxide
Connected elsewhere
Different from cholesterol
In its carbonyl place
Where the carbon is here
Connected to oxygen with two bonds.
Cortisol,
Derived from cholesterol
A type of steroid hormone,
Also has carbon rings
Consisting of six carbonates
The ring is composed
Of five carbonates
Which represents
Stereoscopic installation
Steroid.
As we have seen
That all
Different
Somehow.
Composition of molecules
With three-dimensional figures
And look at it
maybe
Give us an idea
About the shape of particles
But
Does not necessarily give us
Its real shape,
Light reflection
Change the shape of things,
Especially if their sizes are microscopic.
To facilitate consideration
On the stereo
Can imagine
White balls are hydrogen
The gray is the carbon and the red is the oxygen.
and that is
Probability
For cortisol molecules.
Phospholipide is considered
A well-known example
Of amphibathic molecules
This has many common characteristics
With the UltraSlide,
Such as three carbonates
At the basis of the molecule,
whereas
Each of
Three carbonates
Connected
A seed of oxygen,
This is where it might be
Derived from glycerol.
But the difference
Which we can see here
Is that two are carbonates
Connected to fatty acids
The third is connected
Phosphate group.
These are
"R"
Probably
To be a membership chain.
As mentioned earlier
That molecules
Type of
Amphibathic
It has a water-loving tip
And a water loving party.
These fatty acids
Especially the hydrocarbon chain
You will be watery.
In this Party
We have phosphate
With electrical charges,
And molecules with electrical charges
Are inherent
Soluble
In water and thus be water loving.
Unsaturated fatty acid chains
And saturated fatty acid chains
Be different in each type
Of types
Phospholipid,
This type
Of phospholipide
With a watery tip
Connected to a water-loving partner
Suitable to be
Cell wall.
Cell formation
Be in existence
Water-threatening parties
In the center of the wall
And parties
Water loving
Abroad,
Ie that
Water loving party
Be attracted to water
Which
inside of
And outside
cell
And parties
Disgusting
Waterproof
Take
Position
Certain
To get away
About water
In the end
Consists
This membrane
Which
is being
Wall
protection
Of the cell.
We will talk
about this
More
in a
Science
Biology,
I wish
to be
You have become
general idea
About the bear
Of this video.